- [Host] La Scarzuola began
as a Franciscan monastery,
but today, it's an
architectural wonderland.
In the 1950s, an architect
named Tomaso Buzzi
purchased La Scarzuola in Terni, Italy,
with the intention of turning
it into his own ideal city.
Each work is carefully
thought out and built
to represent an inner thought of Tomaso.
He considered this his
autobiography in stone.
La Scarzuola was formed by seven theaters
representing Tomaso's
notion that the ideal life
is symbolically theatrical.
Influenced by Dali and
Escher, his style is a blend
of surrealistic architecture,
and neo mannerist elements
which can be felt in the general unbalance
and disproportionate feel of the place.
These elements are meant
to reflect Tomaso's
passionate belief that
life is both mysterious
and perplexing.
After Tomaso passed in 1981,
his nephew continued
to work on La Scarzuola
to complete his uncle's vision,
allowing Tomaso's ideal city to live on.